good news though for the rams they may
not have to face
kyler murray here is cliff kingsbury
from monday explaining murray's status
after he was injured late in saturday's
laws to the 49ers
he feels this week hopeful that he can
be in position to to play and
you know do what he does we're going to
put him out there if he can't play you
know at a high level and doesn't feel
safe to play but
we'll just have to see how he progresses
if he can't go with strugglers still the
backup
striver is definitely the backup
chris trevler 25 years old played at
south dakota i look i i
i
cover the nfl
all day
every day and even then
i didn't know who the hell chris trevler
was sure did you well yeah but i mean
like you know it was a guy that was a
low-level watch for you know the draft
but not that i sat there and did like
hours and hours of homework on them or
anything like that i mean i think the
big thing is i'm surprised that it's
just a slam dunk there you know i did
read some quotes i thought from the
press conference or maybe it was earlier
in the day where there was a little bit
of a hey we're going to talk about it as
an organization you're going to throw a
rookie who's never played ever before in
over a guy like brett hunley who's
played for the packers and meaningful
football games and a few other times and
showed that he's you know capable and
can make a play i i don't know again
they're they're there every day i know
that but it's a guy from south dakota
who's never played a game
in the nfl
and now it's week 17 and it's a big
moment i i would be a little tentative
that way and not just disrespect you
know chris strebler that way anyway but
just brett hundley's got a you know a
few more pelts on the horse uh than than
stravler
well he's got no pelts on the horse but
but he has at least he has at least
played uh in the nfl now streamler as it
turns out i'm doing my chris trevler
research on the fly he did win the grey
cup in 2019 that's right with the
winnipeg blue bomber so i need to get up
on my cflc chris berman would have known
who chris strebler is yeah well you're
no christian since i don't know that
since i don't
know
since i don't follow the cfl i didn't
know who chris drevler is there's an
awesome photo of him hoisting the grey
cup
in
a fur coat
shirtless underneath yeah and he's a
personality right that's that's right so
so you know what i'm kind of i'm kind of
intrigued by the possibility of the
struggler walford matchup at 4 25 p.m
eastern on sunday uh what what a cluster
of games too at 4 25 p.m eastern we're
gonna have fun getting ready for a seven
o'clock show that's for damn sure yeah
all the impactful games are at 4 25 p.m
eastern on sunday
how do we know what the the kylo murray
injury exactly is i mean i know i've
lower legs yeah lower leg is that as
much as we're gonna get there that's all
we're gonna get is lower leg well
wednesday wednesday we'll get we'll get
whether he's practiced right you know or
whether he was
a
limited participant full participant and
it'll be ankle foot toe
heel
head shoulders knees and toes i don't
know it's going to be in there somewhere
well they have to give you a body part
they can't do the lower leg hockey style
injury disclosure come once who do you
trust who do you trust what team do you
trust to to be able to win a football
game
yeah rams right right rams yeah
just because
just because i i have more faith in
mcveigh he's taking a team to a super
bowl i mean i you know
it's it comes down to that sorry cliff i
mean i'm impressed with what they've
done this year you know they gave us
flashes in arizona that this was going
to be a special season and it's
regressed to just 500 and yeah you have
to wonder
with kingsbury and kyler murray is that
kind of what they're going to be are
they they're going to be a team that
hovers around 500 and one year it's
going to break 10 and 6 and one year
it's going to break 6 and 10 but it's
never going to be dominant that's going
to be the challenge moving forward in
arizona chris well i think so i agreed
with you there and i think you know with
the
i i'm like you i give the advantage to
the rams too because of mcveigh the team
you know arizona their offense it's a
lot of it's based on the pure talent of
kyler murray that's really part of the
genius of it so when that's away
i don't sit there and go wait i think
this offense is going to be able to
execute just like normal like i do with
the rams
you know so i i
the the the cardinals i think your point
is very real
you know good football team fun to watch
have some young players that are very
exciting got some really good areas you
know on their team with some with some
good football players but you know all
in all i still think
that yes to your point
like it's gonna have to be more diverse
in the off season and it's gonna have to
change a little bit with the offense how
they approach the game do all that
because we've seen all year they've kind
of feasted on the week
right they feast on the weak
statistically and then when it's a good
defense it's kind of just like ah
yeah we know you're the number two
offense in football but not against the
good defenses you're the number two
offense in football when it's like the
bottom half of the football and then
when it's the good defenses you're
pretty an average offense and i think
that just shows because it's too kyler
centric they got to do more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports